let's go next to Grant from Iowa City
Grant welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
hey David so you might have already
addressed this question in the past at
some point so I apologize if that's the
case but apology accepted
great but what if anything do you think
can be done to regain the majority of
people's confidence in the fairness and
security of the voting and election
process well he the reason I love this
question is that it's based on a false
premise
and I understand why you're you're
asking it this way most people do trust
the election results that we've had in
the United States it's it's not a
majority that doubts the election
results which should make us ask why do
those claims that most people don't
believe get so much attention and
amplification and it's because there is
one side the Republican party that has
abandoned policy and they want to try to
win through hijinks and election
interference and getting votes thrown
out or closing polling places Etc your
question more generically would be what
can we do to increase confidence in our
election systems but you said how can we
get back to a majority we have a
majority who already trust our election
system
right I think I just I asked it poorly I
guess yeah I was more so wondering like
of the people who don't trust it how do
we regain the majority of like those
people sadly it's not simple and here's
why
when critical thinking
is is weakened and diminished in the
United States it creates a vacuum into
which elected officials on any side
could convince their followers of
obviously untrue things
um you look at some of the people who
say they're going to vote for Herschel
Walker despite all of the claims against
them and they go no well he apologized
and he's denying it and it was something
he did when he was young he was 50. uh
and on and on they can explain it away
however and so when you have such a
population that's vulnerable to
non-thinking and disinformation
Etc
if the Republican Party decides we
benefit from convincing our followers
that the elections aren't Fair it's very
hard to disabuse folks of that belief so
unfortunately I hate to be such a downer
on this we need to in basically
vaccinate people against falling for
false beliefs like this in the first
place which goes back to what we teach
starting in middle school and in high
school and getting people not to fall
for this stuff in the first place so
it's a very big uphill battle
yeah yeah to the extent one other idea
would be
if Republicans stop believing it's to
their advantage to tell the it was
rigged story
then they would stop doing it and I just
broke a glass wow that was very loud
um and uh but but to the extent that
they continue to benefit from that
they're going to keep doing it
probably very true all right well let's
take my call no prob I I I'm actually
wondering how loud that was we do have
broken glass in the studio so we're
gonna have to we're gonna have to deal
with that in a moment but let's continue
with that let's continue with calls for
the time being